hey guys today is the day the a LOI
armor set and bow unlock in master
hunter world so we're gonna show you how
to get it head over to your events and
pick up the rank 6 quest at the proving
which is a fun little reference to an
event in horizon zero dawn you will need
to be hunter rank 11 or higher to do
this you'll be tasked with fighting a
rather large engine ass however it's not
that bad and as long as your gear is up
to snuff you'll take it down no problem
you'll be rewarded with a Nora brave
trophy typically we would get only one
trophy each time but there were times
when we would get to however it doesn't
seem to be set to completion time or
anything so we're not really sure why we
got to sometimes it seems to just be
random for the a low set you're gonna
need for Nora brave trophies along with
14 and a spell pluses 6 engine ass and
nose bone pluses and one engine ass gem
you'll get a fair amount of these
materials each time you do the event so
hopefully you'll have everything you
need the set is a 5 rarity with a
defense of 236 that can be upgraded
further and it has a nice 5 resistance
to everything each piece has a gem slot
with the body getting 2 gem slots and
there's a 2 in 4 set bonus overall while
there are higher to your armor sets in
the game it's actually a pretty good one
in a viable set to use in high rank play
unlike the Ryu set to get a Lloyd's bow
it requires - Nora brave trophies 3
engine effing pluses 5 monster keen
bones and one engine ass plate the bow
is a 5 rarity with a 168 attack thunder
element of 60 and one gem slot you can
however upgrade it further to a war bow
which requires an additional 3 Nora
brave trophies 7 Anjan F scale pluses 3
elder dragon bones and 1 wyvern gem so
you're gonna have to put in a lot more
work for that but you'll be rewarded
with a 6 rarity bow that has an attack
of 192 and thunder element of 80 which
is pretty good and it takes a lot less
work to get then most bows of that tier
so overall outside of getting to play as
a Lloyd which is pretty rad on its own
this seems to be a pretty sweet set of
gear that's well worth the time to get
happy hunting
[Music]